stop caring what other people think
so just got back from teaching at level
6 salsa class at turn O'Day and salsa
and I should have messaged with my
students that they liked and I thought
I'm going to share we believe nation to
and that was a stop caring what people
think we have recent moved into our new
condo and as part of the moving process
you go through old clothes and think you
want to keep on what you're not going to
keep and I had this basket of socks
single socks socks that I couldn't find
a pair for and I was kind of secretly
hoping that one of these days it'll turn
up in the wash that missing extra pair
that goes with these socks I had a bunch
of socks that just weren't being more
and i thought you know i'm going to
check him like i haven't found the
period moving I'm gonna check him I
don't want to thought these single socks
and then I thought about Hayden my son
who's almost seven now and he loves
wearing different colored socks he never
matches his sons we buy his socks in
pairs but he never matches him he
insists on wearing different colored
socks all the time and I go for it
embrace it whatever I don't care you
want to wear pajamas to go to costco you
want to wear cape outside awesome i
don't care so you want to work different
color socks amazing and then I thought
well if he's doing it why shouldn't I be
doing it why should I wear different
colored socks what do they need to match
all the time and the initial instinct
that came back was well what if what if
people like what I keep going to think
if I show up or in different colored
socks and then my default action
whenever I kind of think about that is
who cares like who cares what people
think and then I had to do it of course
right I had to do it if I think that I'm
worried about what other people think
that I had to go and do it of course so
today to class I more difficult in socks
and I told them that they get bonus
points if they wear difficult or talks
as well and that you need to express
yourself and that you shouldn't care
about what other people think and you
got to live your life so here are my
different colored socks they don't match
and I'm owning it today so I hope this
inspires you to tomorrow we're different
colored socks wear mismatched
just for the heck of it and don't care
where the people like that's it hope you
have a great weekend continue to believe
and i'll see you soon